funny fuzzy I almost died
alright so we sold out all the hoodies
but I know you guys like fidget spinners
so now you can buy your official
creditor pie fidget spinner
you ain't spun until you spun this [ __ ]
boy right okay let's get started with
this video let me just doesn't matter
everyone knows this it's been proven
many times that context doesn't have any
effect whatsoever I know where you think
pretty pot context matters a great deal
otherwise everyone is just it can be
whatever they want to be context
mattered reared apart because otherwise
you can twist anyone's narrative to make
them look however you like I know but
this is a false statement I'll prove it
to you just look at enemy everyone Satan
just called don't need to know the
context of this what I do want to know
is why her eyes are so [ __ ] up and
what anime this is because it seems like
an excellent anime is the dragon its
Dragon Ball I do remember that one time
where Satan called
just supported well I was fitting and
more anime examples over that context
doesn't matter I'm not giving up no
matter how big it is I don't see I don't
see a problem with that well what's
weird about that
never give up there's more examples of
anime I'll put it out when it matters
I'll put it I'll pull I'll pull it out
when it matters now that some gay [ __ ]
my mine what the mug is it a new Full
Metal Alchemist is a gay ass enemy but
widget man with amok there's also
context in for streamers you know you're
spending all day talking there's no way
anything that you say can be taken out
of context let me prove it to literally
four-year-old OHS babysitting I was like
I was like [ __ ] his ass when I felt
bad moving on okay anyone else tried the
whole mullah bro edge yet they just came
out here
okay nothing wrong with that one of the
comments says I read online that they
were going to be Slim's and I was super
excited about them now that's a little
gay I was extremely disappointed both
that they weren't slim and that they
have the same weird dirty taste that all
other blacks have oh we all know about
that dirty taste another another typical
reddit racism I had an HP laser at home
that costs me about 400 I went through a
grand total of three toner cartridges
before we lost the printer in a house
fire in 2016 meanwhile a cheap black
brother is like $75 now Roz system that
is extremely resistant I'm disgusted by
this a cheap black brother you see here
context doesn't matter I keep telling
you guys context doesn't matter let's
let's see some more examples here's a
random shot of a couch cleaning up while
your kids are awake it's like wiping
your ass while there is still [ __ ]
coming out there's a thin layer of
toddler covering every surface of okay
okay okay
context still doesn't matter I have
discovered underwater rights it still
doesn't matter
the best of mr. wizard mr. wizard was my
favorite Nickelodeon
there's nothing you can take out of
context from that beautiful they call
yeah big enough to put around you know
now watch the size of this hole would
you come with me please
yeah
would you like to blow nope you can do
it oh my god what the hell is this show
what the hell what the [ __ ] is wrong
with it yeah
oh it's getting bigger yes run this up
and down ten times and what do you think
you're doing with this fantasy what's
the [ __ ] big show what the [ __ ] is
this show what the [ __ ]
cartoons were way better back in the day
I've been missing out man hell yeah
no one no one saw a problem with witted
nine tips seven that no one saw problem
with that no one behind the scenes like
- hey maybe we shouldn't make the kids
do this
[ __ ] you no respect I respect you
producer anything is that you get a
piece of wood that just slips inside
like that the [ __ ] way with that
everything everything no no no no no no
no no no no no I'll show you
help ah how come you can't suck it up
when you do it slowly I don't know okay
well I'm through with you you'll be
sorry you said what you said then when
we've exhausted you and you can't tuck
anymore down it comes here you want to
play with it sure all yours
I thought if I do the acid this man has
no context does not exist in this man's
universe god bless you mr. wizard
god bless yourself cuz god dance I'm so
much off the blow
okay alright I always wondered how much
do I have to blow see that little bead
of surface tension up there yeah
[Applause]
good broke yeah great piece over and out
god bless you mr. wizard god bless your
soul and I keep telling you guys context
doesn't matter
ah it's so obvious have you opened your
ass yet hey Edgar just context matters
shut up you come anyway so let's go and
move on context happens to everyone even
your tripperz your favorite one like Jax
if I normally don't make videos I'm
making this video to write a bandwagon
because anti-semitism I told you it
doesn't matter out of context I don't
feel like very well in my personal life
and I know for a fact that is an
anti-semitic person I'm just trying to
like for the people who are asking is he
a Nazi or not I'm trying to say I'm
monetizing this video how the Wall
Street Journal who broke this story I
don't think they're wrong to actually
break the story then I agree with them
so I don't know how to end this video I
normally don't make videos I told you
guys context doesn't matter it doesn't
matter because clearly this is how is
video what now I asked you guys to prove
as well that context doesn't matter so
let's see what you guys sent me seven
and a half seven inches eight or nine
inches long ten centimeters about four
in Oh beautiful no but god damn it guys
god damn it see that's what I'm talking
about the Turtles
I knew Michele Angelou was my favorite
turtle and I knew I picked a good name
over Turtles hell yeah
this is just [ __ ] weird I'm out of
context I can't
yeah if you still have that tattoo by
the way man yeah hell yeah I've been
watching the wrong anime man this is my
top number one anime strange stuff
happens when things are taken out of
context
ironic that this is that both didn't
okay moving on
they just keep coming and coming and we
don't even know what they are and we
don't know anything that's okay what
they know what they were doing with this
one okay tentacles semen coming uh I
need to start watching Steven universe
now we had a great time talking about
context here today isn't that right mr.
Edgar son hey wake the [ __ ] up wake up
come on I need I need a comment I can't
be taken out of context I am literally
uncontestable that's the word right now
I just trade market on uncontestable
look at my videos for example what deli
on my door no wait oh stop working
wait wait hope you get what you pay me
my heart like I said uncontestable
impossible there's no way you ain't got
nothing on me they got him jack and
everyone else can't on context horizon
me man I love this picture like what the
[ __ ] is happening I don't even remember
this this is sad this is normal
okay everyone does this every youtuber
ever does this ain't nothing out of
context about it ain't nothing out of
context hahaha good job good job
what else do you guys not all you got
let me see that I think there's going to
be a lot of eyes on me during this video
so I'm going to address this as if
anti-semitic but da [ __ ] say you may
have gone in my old videos but there
there's nothing you got on my older
stuff okay
ain't nothing that you can find a my old
stuff all that boring the house they
called us [ __ ]
goddamnit your data suggests a moderate
automatic preference for white piece I'm
racist no no no play please please stop
it stop it everyone just stop alright
this video was singing from @pd PI ideas
it's a Twitter account just dedicated to
give me ideas because I am NOT out of
ideas that is why stop thanking me
thank you transgender okay I really
appreciate you guys to help making these
videos when the times are tough not just
in the monetization but the creativity
and the overall talents I'm just going
to go to the nether realm I don't see a
brooch in the next bit